August 21st 2018 likely the worst day so
far I think is important to add for the
Trump administration Donald Trump's
personal lawyer Michael Cohen pleading
guilty on eight counts Donald Trump's
campaign chairman Paul Manafort found
guilty on eight counts but there is some
good news sort of for Paul Manafort
which is that it is increasingly clear
that sooner or later Donald Trump is
going to pardon the guy for any crimes
that are pardonable by a president
Donald Trump tweeting yesterday I
believe it was quote I feel very badly
for Paul Manafort and his wonderful
family quote justice took a 12 year old
tax case among other things applied
tremendous pressure on him and unlike
Michael Cohen he refused to break make
up stories in order to get a deal such
respect for a brave man yeah I mean
listen
the crimes Paul Manafort committed were
years ago so I guess that means that you
get a free pass this is Trump signaling
in the tweet that he's gonna pardon Paul
Manafort he doesn't insult him first of
all that's already a sign
Trump is probably going to act favorably
because if he's not he's going to insult
you in his tweet number two Trump
dismisses the importance of the case by
saying that the crimes are 12 years old
which of course if the statute of
limitations has not expired then the
statute of limitations hasn't expired
Trump's opinion about when we shouldn't
worry about crimes anymore is wholly
irrelevant and then Trump also says that
Manafort didn't break meaning he didn't
give up dirt on Trump and Trump actually
said in that Fox News interview we
talked about earlier in regards to
Michael Cohen that it should be almost
against the law to cooperate or to flip
which is insane right like what what
crime would it be it should be a crime
to tell the truth to investigators it's
crazy that's how you solve crimes right
you work your way up the organizational
chart and people tell you things that
are presumably the truth so anyway and
then Trump says he has respect for mana
for which is not surprising because
number one Trump respect to all sorts of
criminals and number two Trump doesn't
feel bad for almost anybody right like
Trump did
feel bad for the disabled reporter that
he mimicked and made fun of Trump didn't
feel bad for the parents of deceased
military service members who he insulted
but Trump feels bad for Paul Manafort
somehow so this is a sign if your Trump
you're signalling to Manta for it stay
strong
don't break stick it out and at some
point I'll get you a pardon on the back
end and in reality it makes no sense to
even have to do this because if metaphor
didn't actually commit crimes there'd be
no reason that mana fort would quote
break and tell investigators things
which might be bad for Donald Trump none
of this makes sense and further if Trump
doesn't think metaphor knows anything he
also wouldn't be worried about mana for
cooperating now I know Trump believes
that when people like Cohen quote flip
they make things up all that stuff still
has to be corroborated troubles not
going to be charges won't be recommended
against Trump merely on the basis of
Michael Cohen's say-so
this all could end up being moot though
because Paul mana for it's gonna be
facing more court cases state legal
yes state level and district levels
Manhattan district court yep
so Trump can't pardon him for those
crimes if he is indeed convicted you
know I agree sandbar as presidential
power goes if Trump truly felt that mana
fort committed non crimes decades before
working for him and that Trump also did
nothing wrong
he wouldn't be doing this at all and he
wouldn't be talking about staying strong
or not breaking he would shut up
and he would pardon mana fort in a
couple of years after sentencing
whenever it's all said and done and an
important issue by the way for both
Cohen and mana for more for mana for
since Cohen doesn't seem to be heading
towards a pardon for Trump is that you
can't be pardoned by the president for
just any crimes and federal crimes you
can state crimes you cannot and it is
very rapidly appearing that Michael
Cohen and possibly Paul Manafort could
have state level charges coming against
them and that will be a whole new thing
as I like to say ask me questions about
these charges or anything else on the
David Pakman show
Instagram I've been answering questions
through
the day I will answer more after the
show very easy to do first of all you
got to follow me on the shows Instagram
which is at David Pakman show then look
at our Instagram stories there is a
place where you can type in your
question I'll get a ping when you ask
your question and then I'll answer it if
it's a reasonable question please don't
troll me on the questions follow the
show on instagram at david pakman show
you can also follow me on instagram at
david dot Pakman
great great interview coming up next
today's episode is made possible in part
by better help calm slash Pakman I've
spoken about the unfair and unfortunate
stigma that there can be around therapy
there shouldn't be and better help makes
things even easier for you if you've
been thinking about getting involved and
working with a therapist you get access
to fully licensed experienced
psychologists and therapists through
your phone or computer all you have to
do is go to better help calm slash
Pakman you fill out a questionnaire they
match you with a counselor that'll work
best for you you can ask if you want
that your therapist not be religious if
that is important to you and at any
point if you think your therapist is not
a good fit you can switch and work with
somebody else it's less expensive than
seeing a counselor in person but better
help also gives you unlimited access to
your counselor you can talk to them
every day if you want you will not get
that with an in-person therapist so go
to better help calm slash Pakman so easy
to sign up and get started we've put a
link in the video description if you're
watching on YouTube check it out better
help calm slash PA que ma N